dans l'actualité aussi la justice avec
je vous le disais en titre ce procès à
tours pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
à la barre les deux organisateurs à
montlouis-sur-loire d'une soirée
clandestine soirée organisée en plein
couvre-feu et qui avait rassemblé plus
d'une centaine de fêtards sur place au
palais de justice de tours on retrouve
lucas chopin lucas bonsoir l'audience
s'est elle terminée
bonsoir non l'audience n'est toujours
pas terminée et le programme de cette
soirée du 12 décembre à montlouis est
encore floue tout comme les
responsabilités de chacun alors ce qui
ressort c'est une volonté de la prévenue
claire 24 ans de fêter son anniversaire
en plein confinement et c'est son ami
giresse femmes trois ans et dj qui se
proposent pour organiser lors un bouche
à oreille s'opère sur les réseaux
sociaux et ce sont 100 à 150 personnes
qui se réunissent dans une cave de 120
mètres carrés rue de l'agau dallery sur
place l'entrée est facturé 10 euros pour
les femmes et 30 euros pour les hommes
les deux prévenus ont exprimé des
regrets mais j'ai organisé cette soirée
pour gagner de l'argent explique le
jeune dj aujourd'hui sans revenu un
professionnel et c'est sur cela que va
se jouer le verdict en réalité car la
procureure distingue les soirées
organisées par des jeunes ont soif de
liberté et les soirées à but lucratif
comme celle ci alors elle a requis
quatre mois de prison avec sursis et 210
heures de travaux d'intérêts généraux
contre le dj pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui
au vu de la situation sanitaire bien sûr
la procureur a également requis 140
heures de travail d'intérêt général
contre claire pour complicité cette
fois-ci de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
actuellement dans la salle d'audience
derrière moi les avocats sont en train
de plaider le verdict doit tomber d'ici
quelques minutes